whenever she says that i'm filming right
now there's no way i could talk scott
disick is giving his best kris jenner as
he calls out the family matriarch for
apparently not taking his calls whenever
she says that i'm filming right now
there's no way i could talk yeah i'm
like speak to you it's a reality show
you talk on the phone in real life yep
that's scott imitating chris on the
latest episode of hulu's the kardashians
the reality star stops by chloe's new
house which is next door to chris to
catch up i cannot get over
how close you are oh my god crazy now i
get it
i just was over there i had to measure
something with his family yeah i have to
buy next door yeah even kanye
bought a house across the street yeah if
i ever want to see court again buy a
house i cross the road well yeah i mean
i figured
this would be the move to make
and that's when scott tells coco her mom
has been dodging his calls i got that
she actually does answer the phone no
matter what she usually says i have to
go she always says i'm filming i can't
talk i'm like well they're with me i go
it's also a reality show so your
conversation can be filmed oh my god
whenever she says that i'm filming right
now there's no way i could talk yeah i
might speak to you it's a reality show
you talk on the phone in real life all
jokes aside scott has been having a hard
time adjusting to this new chapter as
his ex courtney moves full steam ahead
with travis barker it's a topic of
conversation later in the episode when
court's sisters hit the gym have you
talked to scott lately he's being such a
baby about courtney and travis
you know
don't you think or not
i think we baby
most of the people in our lives now
literally
and you feed everyone yeah we coddle
them we put them in a little blanket we
hand feed them we do we give them the
cozy collection well maybe not too cozy
for laura disick a source told e.t last
month that scott has a lot of regrets
about how he treated courtney during
their seven-year relationship and chloe
well she seems to be over scott's
feelings like men want to be
nurtured and then when they do they're
like they don't get out of that fetal
position and they're like oh
courtney is engaged it's been seven
years like shut up everyone
all right this is like a new start we
don't need to baby people i'm just like
living life and
whatever happens happens
meanwhile the family is in full support
of courtney's love story with the blink
182 rocker the couple tied the knot in a
lavish italian wedding last month and on
the fam's reality show we get an update
on court and travis's journey to having
a baby we did all these healthy things
and we made love and we made a baby so
now that we feel really healthy we are
going to
try naturally and take a big break from
ivf we're just you know living our best
lives
[Music]
you